because of climate change mountain
glaciers are melting rapidly and
affecting numerous ecosystems but
getting up close readings on these
high-altitude environments is difficult
satellite images don't have enough
detail and can be easily thwarted by
clouds airplanes can map glaciers in
high resolution but the costs can be
astronomical Oliver Whitmore a scientist
at the University of Colorado has
developed a new high-flying drone that
can take images at altitudes of up to
6,000 meters above sea level
normally drones have trouble reaching
these Heights because the air is too
thin for their propellers to build up
enough left but with this new design
weight is kept to a minimum
the tiny aircraft only weighs 2
kilograms and with six individual rotors
each over a foot long generating lift
shouldn't be a problem to give their UAV
a shakedown cruise researchers took it
to the heights of the Andes Mountains in
South America where 70% of the Earth's
tropical ice is located at the melting
glaciers are often what supplies fresh
water to communities in the summer
with the drones help researchers are
able to get close-up pictures and create
detailed models of the glacier surface
using drone surveys collected one year
apart scientists are able to see where
and how quickly the glacier ice is
melting while the flights through the
Andes were the first test of the UAV it
was only the first stop on a world tour
the researchers are taking it to even
greater heights in the Andes and are
using this kind of close-up data
gathering for other environmental
studies in places like the mountains of
Colorado
[Music]
[Music]